un curieux jardin a pris place à la
commanderie des plantes récoltées sécher
et assemblé l'artiste dominique leroy
appel à la déambulation avec son jardin
d'eau une inspiration venue tout droit
du pays le soleil levant c'est un
théâtre donc théâtre médiéval japonais
très lent avec toujours à côté un petit
groupe de musiciens qui accompagnent les
comédiens et qui joue essentiellement
des percussions très très sobre très
basique
ça fait une ambiance un petit peu
solennel fixe etc des petits moteurs les
plantes se frottent étape entre elles
comme des caisses de résonance leurs
fonds deviennent musique au coeur de la
chapelle dominique leroy a été invité
par david de rôle aux chorégraphes ont
carte blanche
c'est sa sensibilité sa poésie et la
magie de ses installations en mouvement
et qui produisent du son on est vraiment
dans du contemplatif dans la rêverie
ce qui me touche c'est lui avec vraiment
voilà il ya pas mal d'électronique hon
se sentir vraiment un gros travail de
composition derrière mais c'est pas non
plus qu'on remarque le pouce un travail
par ordinateur invisible pour le public
l'oeuvre créée en 2017 est à voir à la
commanderie jusqu'au 19 avril